pour la plupart des enfants la saison
estivale est synonyme de grandes
aventures immortalisée dans les camps de
jour et les camps de vacances mais voilà
que plusieurs éclosions auprès du
personnel frappe de plein fouet
certaines institutions
ici aucun waro dans lanaudière au moins
onze moniteurs et deux aspirants
moniteurs sont positifs à la coved 19
la direction a demandé aux parents de
venir chercher leurs enfants aujourd'hui
tout est parti pour un mois une semaine
s'est terminée santé publique avant tout
c'est la vie le mais je comprends qu'ils
appellent des enjeux avec le personnel
c'est sûr s'ils font ce que la saison
sera très difficile les par aimé et
compris c'est pourquoi nous ont fait les
décisions parce que c'est politique et
aider les enfants
l'endroit devrait rouvrir le 13 juillet
prochain au moins deux autres quant au
québec ont dû fermer cette semaine dont
le quinze jours à sept îles où quinze
membres du personnel ont lakovic 19 la
pénurie de mais de fait en sorte qu'on
n'a pas trente moniteurs qui attendent
bond en arrière dans la liste pour
remplacer ceux qui sont en isolement
donc la situation fait en sorte que
rapidement on se retrouve à la solution
d'annuler des activités par voie de
communiqué la santé publique rappelle
que la décision de fermer ou non un camp
review gestionnaire de l'établissement
il n'apparaît pas opportun de tester
systématiquement l'ensemble des
participants et des employés le port du
masque est recommandé aux personnes dont
la situation les rend plus vulnérables
pour rappel qu'on opéré l'été dernier
sans éclosion en cartes vacances mais on
avait au préalable les tests pcr pour
les quarts est-ce que c'est une mesure
qu'on peut remettre en place on aimerait
ça par contre mettre l hémorragie nous
on veut rencontrer la santé publique dès
aujourd'hui québec promet de rencontrer
les représentants de l'industrie
prochainement ici marie michel lauzon
radio canada montréal